60 m de descente en rappel et une vue
imprenable sur tours telle est la
promesse de cette attraction inédite à
l'aide de cette nacelle installée place
anatole france une centaine de tours en
jeu sont venu vaincre leur peur du vide
l'expérience riche en sensations et en
émotions leur en met plein la vue ah bon
on voit toujours on va tous les
monuments de touron voilà trousseau même
les magasins et qui enfin on voit
vraiment bien l'étendue c'était très
impressionnant des 60 m
tout là-haut et puis à un moment
d'appréhension quand il faut basculer
dans le vide est les premiers matches
les effets les yeux fermés j'avoue faut
pas trop regarder juste en bas
directement mais après une faconde est
censé les ans ça fait bizarre de
retourner sur le sol à l'origine de ce
challenge le club de spéléologie de
touraine le plus grand de la région
objectif récolter des dons pour
l'association la table de jeanne-marie
grand pour la pauvreté et les réfugiés
ukrainien même si l'opération reste
gratuite
les participants sont invités à faire un
don de 10 euros minimum depuis 2014 elle
a lieu deux à trois fois par an pour le
plus grand plaisir de ses organisateurs
on adore faire cette opération parce que
déjà premièrement au sein du club ça
fait une émulation
tout le monde est uni pour faire ce
projet qui nous enthousiasme et ça nous
enthousiasme parce qu'on voit le sourire
de tous les participants qui adorent
voir le paysage donc ce bonheur que
qu'on donne aux gens
on le reçoit nous on en est très content
pour ceux qui auraient loupé cet
événement rendez vous début décembre
lors du téléthon